>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
[ Silence ]
>> John Cole: Well, good afternoon,
and thank you for joining us
at the Library of Congress.
I'm John Cole.
I'm the director of the Center for
the Book in the Library of Congress,
which is the reading and literacy
promotion arm of the Library.
We were created -- renewing
our 40th anniversary.
This is -- we were created in 1977
by the historian Daniel Boorstin
when he was Librarian of
Congress, and he wanted the Library
of Congress to have a way to
reach out to the general public
to promote books and reading, and
now literacy and libraries as well.
And we are active in a number of
events and programs, both nationally
and here at the Library of Congress.
We were in at the beginning
of the National Book Festival,
which is in Washington
now in September.
And it started in 2001 in
the Center for the Book
with its ongoing author
program of noontime talks
that you're attending, thank
you, actually started in 1996,
and it's called "Books and Beyond".
So we have a long history of author
promotion and book promotion.
This particular series
focuses on new books by authors
who have used the Library
of Congress,
and other libraries in their work.
And our purpose is to make certain
that there's a public appreciation
of the results of the research
that's done in libraries
around the country, and also to
promote these particular books
in a way that will be productive,
we hope not only for the audience,
but for the author, and for the
whole enterprise of publishing.
The way it works is follows.
We will hear from our guest author,
and there will also be a brief
period for questions and answers,
and then a book signing at the end.
Today's program is being filled
both by the Library of Congress
for its own website and archive.
We now have over 350 of these author
programs in the archive of Books
and Beyond, which are available on
the Library of Congress's website,
not to mention, website
productions of many author programs
at the National Book Festival.
We just had our 15th anniversary,
and we've had something like many,
many hundreds of authors who have
been part of that book festival.
Today's program is also being
filmed by C-SPAN, which is wonderful
in terms of being able to reach out
nationally, and for this program
to be part of the C-SPAN archive.
We will have time for a brief
question and answer period
at the end, and we hope that
you will have questions.
I know that our author
will have answers.
And I want to remind you that by
asking a question and being part
of that, you are really giving
us permission to perhaps be part
of the -- at least the Library
of Congress program
and website broadcast.
Josh Kendall, our speaker today,
is an award-winning journalist,
and now a critically-acclaimed
biographer who lives in Boston.
He's published many articles in
newspapers, Wall Street Journal,
the Los Angeles Times, the
New York Times, USA Today,
and Psychology Today, which I
think when I saw that I said, "Aha,
that's where Josh gets some of
those insights he's showing,
his psychological insights that
we will probably hear a little bit
about in today's presentation.
He's been writing books, at
least, I believe since --
Josh I don't have this right.
This was -- "The Man Who Made
Lists" was published in --
>> Joshua Kendall: 2008.
>> John Cole: 2008.
And his first book --
well, first of all,
Josh always takes a particular
angle on his subjects,
and I find it interesting,
and I'm always interested
in how he has not only
chosen his subject,
but what part of it
that he's emphasizing.
And I finally figured out that
he has a not-too-hard to figure
out a special place in his
heart for obsessed people.
And often they are book people.
His first book, 2008, is titled,
"The Man Who Made Lists: Love,
Death, Madness and the
Creation of Roget's Thesaurus".
His next book, two years
later, came, it was called,
"The Forgotten Founding
Father: Noah Webster's Obsession
and the Making of an
American Culture".
And then finally he got right
to it with the third book,
which is called, "America's
Obsessives."
And here he presents biographical
profiles of seven American icons,
including Thomas Jefferson,
Charles Lindbergh, and Melvil Dewey,
who was the founder of
the Dewey Decimal system,
and himself quite a wonderful but
absolutely obsessive personality.
Now he has tackled and is
publishing in this election year,
a book about another complicated
topic; I held it up once.
It's called, "First Dads:
Parenting and Politics
from George Washington
to Barack Obama".
And here he's had to make
some careful selections
that I'm sure he'll tell us about.
But basically it brings together the
personal histories of our presidents
from yet another new angle,
their experience as fathers.
And I'm very pleased to be able to
present to you for his latest take
on American obsessives and
American presidents, Josh Kendall.
Let's give him a round of applause.
[ Applause ]
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Joshua Kendall: Thank
you very much, John.
It's a pleasure to be here.
I think this is the third talk I've
done at the Library of Congress.
I spoke about a couple of my --
one of my word nerds, Noah Webster,
the forgotten founding father, the
author of Webster's Dictionary.
And then I also spoke about the
"America's Obsessives"
a few years ago.
When we learn about presidents, we
tend to learn to learn about them
for the first time in grade school.
And the presidents are
almost godlike figures.
We learn about Washington
and Lincoln.
And they're kind of statues.
I mean, they're -- it's as
if in childhood they're all
on Mount Rushmore, and
that's all we know.
And then later in life, maybe as
teenager or young adult, or adult,
we start reading some biographies.
And we get a sense, "Hmm, they're
not all they're cracked up to be,"
maybe, you know, they're
very flawed.
And we tend to think of presidents
in very idealized terms, or --
either idealize them
or denigrate them.
And what I'm trying to do is capture
how complicated presidents are.
They're many-sided.
And I really want to talk
about presidential character.
And I think and the way into
that is through the family.
What kind of father
was George Washington?
was Abraham Lincoln?
And I want to give readers a feel
for what it was like to have dinner
or spend a weekend with
any of these presidents,
and that will give
you a sense of the man
and the decision-making process.
And James David Barber, a
political scientist in the '70s,
wrote a book about
presidential character, and said,
"The issues will change,
but the character
of the president will last."
So when we think of presidents, we
tend to think of policy; you know,
"What was his foreign policy?
What was his economic policy?"
But I think what I'm trying to focus
on is how the president
makes decisions.
And we can learn a
little bit about that
through how the president
decides how much time to spend
with his children, whether
to punish his children,
whether to encourage his children;
and so that it's parenting
and politics from George
Washington to Barack Obama.
Now, the information about
the presidents' kids,
there hasn't been much
written on this topic.
One reason is that the families have
tended to hide this information.
Families don't want people
like me, biographers,
snooping around to find out, you
know, what happened to the kids.
Some of the letters of John
Adams to one of his children
who died young are missing.
And so the families tend to
guard against this information.
And also historians have often
overlooked the family relationships.
And for historians, this is
all considered squishy stuff.
Why would it matter whether -- what
kind of dad Franklin Pierce was.
And what I've learned that
it's not squishy stuff.
For instance in 2016,
one of the reasons
that Joe Biden is not
challenging Hillary Clinton
for the Democratic nomination
is that he lost a child.
And I wrote a piece for the New York
Times when that happened in October
when he decided not to run.
And going back to Franklin
Pierce, I have a category to talk
about grieving dads,
dads who lost children.
Franklin Pierce in 1853,
he was a dynamic person,
and he was considered --
you know, he was elected
in 1852 two months before
he was about to take office.
He takes the train from Andover with
his third and only surviving son,
Benny, who's 11 years old.
That train crashes, Benny
gets a hole in his head;
something falls on Benny's head.
Pierce has to pick up Benny
with a hole in his head.
Benny dies.
And Pierce has posttraumatic
stress disorder.
His brain is fried.
A couple of weeks later,
he writes Jefferson Davis,
his secretary who is going to
become the secretary of state,
"I don't know how I can go on."
And Pierce is totally out of
it for his administration.
His wife literally goes psychotic
and starts writing letters
to her dead children, and the civil
war deepens under, you know, his --
I mean, the civil war hasn't started
yet, but I'm saying the crisis
between the states gets much worse.
So he's not really
there as president.
And the same is true
of Calvin Coolidge.
In 1924, Calvin Coolidge is about
to run for a term of his own.
Remember in 1933 when
Calvin Coolidge dies,
the New Yorker journalist Dorothy
Parker says, "How could they tell;
because he's half asleep."
Well, before 1924, Calvin
Coolidge is a dynamo.
He's proposing all kinds of things.
In July of 1924, just as he's
about to start his own campaign,
his 16-year-old son drops dead after
cutting his toe on the tennis court.
It would something that would
be treated very easily today;
his son Calvin, Jr. And that's when
he starts sleeping 11 hours a day,
and that's when he's --
but he has five more years
to serve in the White House.
So I argue -- and I go through
it in quite a bit of detail
in the chapter, that his
depression may well have caused the
Great Depression.
So this isn't squishy stuff.
This is about the lifeblood
of American history.
And just think about it, George
Washington is our first president.
One of the reasons why George
Washington was elected president,
obviously he was very competent
and, you know, was a dynamic leader
who brought the country together;
but Washington had no
biological children.
And after we kicked the
bricks out of our face,
we didn't want to have another king.
And Washington was a safe choice.
And he writes this in a
draft to his first inaugural.
He says, "And you can trust me as
your president that I'm not going
to pass on the reigns
of power to my son."
And again, this isn't squishy stuff.
That fatherhood has
a deep connection
to the fabric of American history.
And, you know, again, I think
we're facing that issue.
And initially in this election
it looked like was going
to be dynasty versus dynasty.
So again, Americans hate dynasties.
And maybe that was one
of the reasons why Jeb Bush
had, you know, difficulty.
And this, again, goes back to
the case of George Washington.
All right; let me talk a
little about my method.
So this is a nonpartisan book; I'm
taking the long view of history.
This is an election year, and I
don't want to encourage people
to vote for one candidate
or the other, but just think
about the issues, think
about character.
So we've had 43 Presidents.
Grover Cleveland was
president twice,
and we've had 38 had biological
kids, including one of them who lied
about it, Warren Harding;
Warren Harding.
So I have a chapter on presidents;
I call them "double dealing dads",
presidents with illegitimate kids.
So but the other five
presidents all adopted kids.
So we have a database to --
like Washington adopted
Martha's surviving kids.
So we have a database to analyze
all the presidents as fathers.
And I put the presidents
in six buckets.
Preoccupied is the most common.
So as Jimmy Carter --
Jack, his eldest son,
said, "Dad was one-track.
You don't get to be president
unless you're driven."
So I mean, that's the most
common category is the preoccupy.
These are people who are thinking
about politics all the time.
Lyndon Johnson once said, "Oh,
I think about politics
only 18 hours a day."
I spoke to Lucy Johnson, and she
said that her sister Linda used
to read the Congressional Record
so she could get some
face-time with LBJ.
LBJ could not say, "Hi,
Linda, how was your day?"
That would mean that, you know,
that's not about politics.
But if he and Linda could talk
about the congressional
record, then they could connect.
And the girls picked that up.
So that's the largest
category, the preoccupied.
Other categories are playful; Teddy
Roosevelt is a famous example.
Teddy Roosevelt would work in the
afternoon, and then maybe at 3:00,
he would take off and play
tag in the attic with his son.
And his friends were called
"the White House Gang".
Then I have the double-dealing dads,
dads with illegitimate children.
Warren Harding -- and a lot of
the material on Harding is here
at the Library of Congress.
And there's now DNA evidence proving
that the mistress who claimed
that they had sex in the coat closet
in the White House wasn't lying.
The DNA evidence came out last year.
And the story about Harding is
that there was a book in 1928
by the mistress, and no one
believed it at the time.
But then in 1964, a Harding
biographer stumbled on hundreds
of love letters to another mistress;
and that mistress is
Carrie Phillips.
So if he was carrying on with Carrie
Phillips, then the man Britain,
her story, seemed much
more believable.
And actually, the Library of
Congress has just released all
of those Carrie Phillips letters
in the last couple of years.
So preoccupied, playful,
double dealing.
Another category is Tiger Dads.
You may have heard
of Amy Chua's book
about the Tiger Mom,
very tough dads.
John Adams and John Quincy
Adams fall into that category.
And Tiger Dad can either
make or break their kids.
John Adams had John Quincy Adams,
and he basically told John Quincy
when he was a young man "Either
you're going to be president,
or you're going to be a failure."
And John Quincy became president,
but a couple of his other
kids had gotten depression,
and didn't do so well.
Other categories are
the grief-stricken;
I mentioned Pierce and Coolidge.
And the last category are the
sweet dads, the nurturing dads.
Our current president whatever
one thinks about is politics,
I think everyone acknowledges
that he's a great dad.
And but there were actually
some sweet ones going back
to the 18th Century.
James Monroe was very sweet.
And Obama is a first
sort of modern dad.
I mean, Obama, as I told a reporter
from The Guardian the other day,
is the first presidential dad,
at least in my calculations,
to do diapers.
And we're probably going
to see more of that.
There are going to be more
nurturing dads in the 21st Century.
But what's interesting is that there
were still some in the 18th Century.
And some presidents are
in more than one category.
For instance, George Herbert Walker
Bush was both a preoccupied dad --
Jeb Bush once told a biographer, "At
least he didn't put us in a kennel."
George Bush was based in Houston,
and he would fly back to Connecticut
on business, and leave
Jeb and George W. Bush,
you know, back in Houston a lot.
And Jeb said, "At least we
weren't put in the kennel;
we were put with other, you
know, friends of the family."
But George Herbert
Walker Bush he was very --
and the preoccupied dads,
they love their kids,
but they're just very,
very ambitious.
And they're just -- so one of
the subtypes is the absentee dad.
But George Herbert Walker Bush
also was a grieving father.
He lost his daughter,
Robin, the second child.
She was about four
in the early '50s.
And that -- so he falls
into both categories.
And that loss actually gave us a
playful dad, because George W. Bush,
his eldest son who became
president, he was the --
Barbara became very depressed
after this horrific loss.
Apparently, that's when
her hair became white.
And George W. Bush became
very playful with his mother
in an effort to cheer her up.
And he, then, was also very
playful with his two daughters,
and I talk a little bit
about him as a playful pal.
Right; and in each chapter what
I did is I took three stars.
So there are 43 presidents,
and I wanted to say something
about each president.
But for instance, the
preoccupied dads, I talk about FDR,
Lyndon Johnson, and Jimmy Carter.
So I have three stars, and then I
fold in a lot of other presidents,
Richard Nixon, or William
Howard Taft.
So there are 18 presidents
I profile in depth.
And for those 18 presidents, I did
archival research, either here,
or at the FDR library,
whatever I could find documents.
And for those presidents, I
also interviewed family members.
I interviewed a couple of --
several of FDR's grandchildren.
Some of them are as old as 90 now.
And it was exciting just to talk
to someone who was there, you know,
when he -- 1933 when
he was inaugurated,
she was about four or five.
But that was just very exciting.
And then for Jimmy Carter,
I spoke with his son, Chip.
So for the 20th Century presidents,
I tried to do interviews
as much as possible.
And then for 18th and
19th -- or for --
you know, for 19th and early
20th Century presidents,
I relied on archives.
And I try to say something
about them all.
So I even say something
about Chester Arthur.
You know, no one remembers
who Chester Arthur was,
Garfield's vice president.
And I found out that he was very
playful with his son, and his son,
Alan Arthur, became a
playful polo player,
in case you wanted to know that.
[Laughter] All right; preoccupied
is the largest category.
So again, that's the
way to become president.
And FDR, LBJ and Carter -- and I'd
estimate about 40% of presidents fit
into this category, Van
Buren, Taft, Nixon, Reagan.
And then also this election --
I just wrote a piece
for Parade Magazine;
this election is kind
of a rejection of Obama.
Obama's a nurturing
dad, who's a connector.
And in this election, we're sort of
going back to the preoccupied dads.
Both -- Hillary Clinton's not
a dad, preoccupied parent,
but she was very ambitious,
you know, like her husband.
And same with Donald Trump.
I interviewed Donald Trump's
-- one of his sons, Eric.
And Eric, when he was ten years old,
was working with his father
at construction sites.
And Jimmy Carter's children
were working on the peanut farm
at age ten; were collecting
peanuts and driving tractors.
So the preoccupied fathers connect
with their children through work.
And Obama is very different.
Obama, like Harry Truman, is very
interested in sort of promoting,
you know, his girls
and their development.
But the standard preoccupied dad --
or mom in the case of Mrs. Clinton,
is -- and Chelsea, you know,
works for the foundation,
and her connection --
she's been campaigning
since she was two years
old, I mean, her connection
to her parents is through work.
And with FDR -- and sometimes,
the president is the same
with the country as
with his children.
John Adams gave us the
Alien and Sedition Acts.
He was kind of an authoritarian
president,
and he was an authoritarian dad.
FDR was a father figure
to his country.
When he dies in 1945, most Americans
felt as if they had lost a father.
And he was a very inspiring
leader who instilled hope.
But with his own children,
FDR a different side came out.
And his children literally
held him up.
The book starts in 1924 at the
Democratic National Convention
when FDR makes his comeback
after polio, and his son, James,
is holding him up, because,
you know, he can't walk.
And FDR, with his children, the
children are parentified [phonetic].
So with his own children,
he treats his own children
as if they were his parents.
His own children are
kind of raising him up so
that he can raise the country up.
And when James is young,
he wants to me meet --
one of the children is young,
he wants to meet his father.
And they had to make
appointments in the White House.
And the boy wants to -- the
adolescent is going to get married,
and he wants to talk to FDR and
in the middle of the meeting,
FDR shoves a document in
his son's face and says,
"What do you think about this?"
And the boy rushes out of the
Oval Office and tells Eleanor,
"I'm never going to talk to him
about anything serious again."
And FDR, again, to his own
children, is a bit neglectful
but to the country,
he's very empathic.
And, you know, Ronald Reagan
was another great communicator
who inspired the country
with his infectious optimism,
but he kind of alienated
his own children
who he didn't really connect with.
Now, Jimmy Carter, as I said
had -- everyone forgets that --
most people who were around during
the Carter administration forget
that Jimmy Carter had these three
sons , that's Chip, Jeff, and Jack.
We all remember Amy because
she was very photogenic,
and she was going to primary school.
But Jimmy Carter had the three sons.
And Jimmy Carter -- at
first the sons work with him
in the peanut farming, and
they start working at ten.
And then the three sons in the
mid-70s are all in their 20s.
And they're all married;
they all marry young.
And they're his campaign staff.
So again, his children
-- without his children,
there would be no Jimmy Carter
winning the Iowa Caucuses,
because he had a built-in staff
of six when he was a nobody.
And Jimmy Carter is on
"What's My Line" either in --
I think it's late '74 or early
'75, and they can't even guess
who he is, the governor of Georgia.
No one knows about him.
But he's got this staff
of six and his children.
And he is very grateful.
To his credit he's very appreciative
of how much his children helped him,
just as FDR's children
propped him up.
[ Paper Sounds ]
All right; the playful pals, Grant,
Teddy Roosevelt, and Wilson --
and Wilson is -- everyone
knows about Teddy Roosevelt,
but Wilson is an interesting
case because we think of Wilson
as this dour intellectual,
which he was.
But a whole different side of him
came out with his three daughters.
One of his -- his middle
daughter, Jessie, describes him as,
"A curious mix of dignity
and almost wild gaiety."
He loved dancing with his daughters.
When he was in the White House,
he would do chicken fighting,
which is a kind of, you know,
pushing each other, you know,
dancing up and down the corridors.
And his brother-in-law, who
lived in the White House,
Stockton Axon once said, "What would
the great American public think
if they could see their
austere president now?"
So Wilson is a whole different
ballgame inside the family,
than he was in public.
So the three stars of
that chapter are Grant,
Teddy Roosevelt, and Wilson.
And Grant was actually
a very sensitive dad
who loved playing with his kids.
And again, he was a general.
And in the South, when
they think of Grant,
they think of a violent killer.
But he loved playing with his kids.
And there's also the question
of Grant and his alcoholism.
And I found that Grant was
a sensitive family man,
and he drank when he couldn't
be around his children.
I found some very tender letters
that he writes to his wife.
And he's lapsing into 21st
Century psychology, saying,
"I'm so attached to my boys.
I miss them."
And that's when he starts drinking.
So that gave me new insight
into Grant's character.
Now the double-dealing dads,
the heart of the matter.
My three stars of this
chapter are John Tyler,
Grover Cleveland and Warren Harding.
I talked a little bit about Harding.
John Tyler -- Tippecanoe and Tyler
[phonetic] to the election of 1840,
that was the most fertile ticket.
Harrison had about ten children.
Tyler had about eight
children with his first wife.
Then he marries a second
wife in 1844,
the last year of his presidency, and
has another seven children with her.
But there are also oral histories,
and the oral history suggests
that both Harrison, as well
as Tyler, had slave children.
And Tyler -- I went
snooping around in Virginia;
the oral history suggests that --
there's an account
that Tyler bragged
about having 52 slave children.
That's hard to prove, but there
were allegations that came
out in the press in the 1840s
about some of these slave children.
And I looked, and the most striking
allegations are that he sold a few
of the slave children;
so double-dealing dad.
And I argue that Tyler both
betrayed these children,
and also betrayed the
country, because during --
when the civil war started,
there were five ex-presidents,
and only one of them sided with
the Confederacy; that was Tyler.
And when he dies in 1862, Lincoln
refuses to acknowledge his death,
and considers him a traitor.
So as I said, sometimes the dad and
the politician are of the same ilk.
And that's my argument with Tyler.
And then I -- you know,
Thomas Jefferson --
a lot has been written
about Thomas Jefferson
as a double-dealing dad,
and I don't go into him.
And then LBJ may have
had an illegitimate kid.
There are cancelled checks
from a woman who wrote a memoir
about an illegitimate child.
And LBJ definitely was
a bit of a sex maniac.
He once bragged to his staff
and said, "I had as many women
by accident as JFK had by design."
So the allegations are
definitely believable.
And again, what I do in the
chapter is just present the evidence
that there is.
Some cases, it's kind
of a slam dunk,
some cases, the evidence isn't much.
But just to -- the three that
Tyler, Cleveland, and Harding --
in the case of Harding, there's DNA
evidence, and Cleveland does admit
that he fathered a
child out of wedlock.
And that was a big issue --
again, that was a big issue
in the campaign of 1884.
So again, this isn't just
squishy stuff about --
this was also that election pivoted
around an illegitimate child.
All right; the grief-stricken,
Pierce --
my three stars are Pierce,
McKinley, and Coolidge.
Pierce I told you about.
McKinley has two daughters in the
1870s, both die by the age of four,
and his wife becomes
chronically depressed.
But again, it's not squishy stuff,
because it inspires
McKinley to go into politics.
And that's kind of his brand.
His brand was this sensitive
man who'd experienced this loss,
who was very supportive of his wife.
His wife suffers a stroke,
and his wife is semi-invalid
for the rest of her life.
And she's very depressed.
And what people loved about McKinley
when he's first elected is that he
and his wife -- that
he is very sensitive
to his wife, and a
caring family man.
So out of this tragedy, it's
kind of polio made FDR --
you know, some of the
biographers have said
that that tragedy helped
FDR empathize,
and helped him grow as a politician.
And the same can be said
with McKinley and his losses.
And another interesting
example of a grieving dad --
he's not a star in my chapter,
but someone I talk about, is JFK.
You may have forgotten that JFK
loses his son in 1963 a few years --
a few months before
he's assassinated.
And that didn't so much have
an effect on national policy,
but it did affect his marriage.
JFK was kind of carrying on with
various women as has been reported.
And his relationship with his
wife was kind of cold for most
of their time in the White House.
But in his last few
months of his life,
he and his wife really
reconnected over this shared loss.
So it did have an effect
on the marriage.
And, you know, JFK was
really evolving, you know,
when he was tragically killed.
[ Silence ]
Okay; the Tiger Dads are John Adams,
and John Quincy Adams
was also a Tiger Dad.
His son -- when one of his
sons -- he had three sons,
and one of his sons is 45th out
of 85th in his class at Harvard.
And he says, "Don't bother coming
home for Christmas vacation."
And then he says -- then when
his son does better, he said,
"I'm not going to go to your
Harvard graduation unless you're
in the top ten."
So he's always kind of changing the
goalpost, to use a modern metaphor.
And another example of a
Tiger Dad is Eisenhower.
He's a military guy.
Eisenhower had a son John.
We think of Eisenhower as
kind of a daughter and golfer.
I mean, he was in his 60s, you
know, for most of his presidency.
But, you know, he was doing,
you know, hundreds of push-ups,
you know, well unto his 50s, and
was an amazing physical specimen.
As a -- at army he tackled Jim
Thorpe; he was like a linebacker.
And his son, John, once said, "My
father never hit me, but if he had,
he would have killed me."
And John said that he was born
standing at his attention;
and his father would
give him orders.
And Eisenhower also had a
bad temper, and that's one
of the things about Tiger Dads.
And Eisenhower used to
bark at his aides a lot,
and Eisenhower then used
to tell them, "Well,
my mother taught me how
to control my temper."
And then as soon as he left the
room, one of the aides would say,
"And she didn't do a very good job."
[Laughter]
[ Paper Sounds ]
All right; and now
the nurturing dads.
Rutherford B. Hayes -- remember,
we have the Easter Egg Roll,
which is the largest event in
the White House every year.
Well, that's the child -- to use
the prevailing metaphor of the day,
that's the child of
Rutherford B. Hayes.
He was very sweet to his
own children, and one day --
in those days, the president
could kind of walk around --
you know, go out Pennsylvania
Avenue and take a walk.
He's walking in the neighborhood
and a strange kid comes
up to him [inaudible]
and says, "Hey,
can we roll our eggs on your lawn?"
And he says, "Let me talk to my
people, and I'll get back to you."
And he says, "Sure."
He was just a sweet dad.
And he went for it.
Harry Truman was also very
sweet to his daughter, Margaret.
Margaret describes herself
as a total daddy's girl.
And you may not remember
that Bess Truman,
she hated publicity,
and was very shy.
And she was traumatized
early in life.
When she was 18 years
old back in Independence,
her father blew his
brains out in the house.
And Truman was actually afraid of
running, even being on FDR's ticket
in 1944 because of the publicity.
Suicide then was a
very shameful thing.
And Bess was just nervous,
and just kind
of a lifelong struggle,
kind of private person.
So Margaret just loved her daddy.
And a cute story is that Margaret
wanted to become a singer.
In the 1940s, she graduates
from George Washington.
And Bess, who's kind of stern,
says, "You don't want to --
you can't become a singer, you
know, this is America in the 1940s.
You've got to get married
and have kids."
And Harry says, "No, no, no;
if she wants to be a warbler,
let her be a warbler."
He's very supportive.
And again, today, Obama is
going to do something like that.
The nurturing dads are a
little more commonplace.
But that was rare for the time.
And one of the fascinating things I
found about the nurturing dads was
that the nurturing dads did not
really have dads themselves.
For instance, I mean,
obviously, Obama has a father,
but he only spent about two months
with his own father from Kenya.
And Rutherford B. Hayes'
father dies before he's born.
So both of these men father
as they were mothered.
So people have said, "Well,
Bill Clinton is the
first black president."
Well, I think in many ways,
Barack Obama is almost the
first female president.
He has a very feminine
way of relating.
You know, he's very
nurturing to his children,
and he's nurturing to the country.
And as I said in this
election, I think we're --
America is tired of that,
we want a stronger dad;
we want a stronger authority figure.
And I said in my piece for "Parade"
that I think Americans might
appreciate him more when he's gone,
just the fundamental
decency of the nurturing dad,
whether that's Hayes,
or Truman, or Obama.
When Truman left in 1952, his
popularity was like at 22%.
And everyone thought he was -- he
got a lot of the same criticism
as Obama, that he doesn't
stand up strongly enough,
he's trying to help
everyone get along.
But, you know, David McCullough
wrote that biography 25 years ago,
and there's just this sense
that Truman is now considered
just a very decent man,
and we really appreciate him.
And I think some of the same
is going to be felt about Obama
by generations who have no, you
know, recollection of him actually,
you know, being in the White House.
All right; I just want to
show you a few pictures.
[ Silence ]
So here is FDR with his eldest son.
So his children are always holding
him up, and that was the nature
of the relationship, that, as
I said, he nurtured the country
and his children kind
of nurtured him.
[ Silence ]
And here's FDR with his
eldest daughter, Anna --
I mean, eldest child,
Anna, the one daughter.
And again, the relationship
of parenting --
or of children in history -- I
did a piece for "Politico" talking
about Anna and her
effect on history.
Anna may well have kept FDR
alive for an extra year or so.
She was living in the White House,
and FDR's doctors had no idea how
serious his heart condition was.
And Anna, you know, noticed how
frail he was, and was on top
of his health condition, and at
Yalta, she is watching over him
like a hawk to make sure that
he can attend to business.
So again, these children --
these relationships are really
critical to American history.
[ Silence ]
Here's -- you know, this
is the Chip, you know,
Carter when he was younger.
I think that's at the
-- yes running in '76;
and then the one I showed
you of Amy Carter, you know,
the one child everyone
remembers and her three brothers.
Here's Franklin Pierce.
And Franklin Pierce
was very handsome.
He was a great speaker,
and there was
so much hope when he gets elected.
He's the last Democrat to
win a majority of the vote
until Woodrow -- in 1912
he's a very promising figure.
And he's just totally crushed
by the loss of his son, Benny,
and he's just never the same.
[ Silence ]
And another -- and here's Calvin
Coolidge, Jr. This is the boy
who dies in 1924, and so Coolidge
had two sons, John and Cal,
Jr. And Cal, Jr. is
lionized as a national hero.
He was just a really
sweet kid, and he was all
over the papers during
Coolidge's second term.
[ Silence ]
Here's that austere Tiger
Dad, John Quincy Adams.
He looks the part.
And here's George Washington Adams.
And this is the saddest
story in the book.
George Washington Adams buckles
under at Harvard under the pressure
of the Tiger Dad, his eldest son.
And his name is George Washington.
So John Quincy is basically saying,
you know, presidency or failure.
He does very well at Harvard.
He wins a big literary
prize, best in [inaudible].
So he's promising.
But then, he starts drinking, he has
an affair with an Irish mistress,
and produces an illegitimate child.
And when Adams is leaving
here in Washington in 1829,
he writes to George and says,
"Come to Washington from Boston.
Please come and help me move."
And George is terrified that his
father is going to go back to Boston
and see what a mess
he's made of his life,
find out about his
illegitimate child,
and he kills himself en
route, he jumps off a ship,
and he's about 28,
which is the saddest.
And this is the Tiger Dad.
I mean, just -- you know,
he's either make or break,
and this would be -- you know,
maybe it was a genetic condition.
I mean, I don't, you know, want
to say it's his fault or anything,
but just the toughness, you know,
it can be really overwhelming
for the children.
But again, another of his
sons, Charles Francis Adams,
does very well and his
presidential timber.
But this child, this
is really the saddest.
But in general -- and I've
written for Smithsonian Magazine
and couple other places, in
general, the first children --
until the current crop and
the Bush girls are doing well,
and Chelsea Clinton's doing well.
But in the 19th Century, they
used to talk about the curse
of the presidential child, that --
because these men were also driven,
and they really didn't put a
lot of time into their families.
And they love their kids,
but they just -- it was a --
you know, they had -- the
family was second fiddle,
and a lot of the kids suffered.
And sometimes it's just bad luck
like Benny Pierce being killed.
You know, Franklin Pierce was
actually a very sensitive dad,
but it was just bad luck that
Benny died; but this sense
that the first children were cursed.
[ Silence ]
All right; here is John Eisenhower.
And this is an amazing story.
John Eisenhower is with his
mother, and he graduates
from West Point on June 6th, 1944.
And that's where my chapter starts.
And right after that graduation, he
goes to visit his father in Europe.
And his father, you know, is a
nervous wreck because of D-Day.
And he's sort of watching, you
know, "What's going to happen here,
you know, when the
war is a disaster?"
So there's a month-long
father-son bonding.
And Eisenhower, again,
as a Tiger Dad, you know,
he's criticizing John's bridge
game, and he's criticizing John
for his uniform is dirty.
You know, they take a jeep ride
and John's uniform gets
dusty, and Ike criticizes him.
And, you know, he was very tough.
John actually -- again, the
Tiger Dad can make or break,
John actually does very well.
He just died a couple of years ago.
He was the eldest presidential
child; he dies at about 90.
But he became a biographer
-- a military historian,
and wrote a couple of bestsellers,
and sort of found his
niche as a writer.
[ Silence ]
And here is the playful -- this
is a letter of Teddy Roosevelt.
Teddy Roosevelt's writing to Alice,
and he writes these playful letters.
And again, the effect on history,
Teddy Roosevelt wins
the Nobel Prize in 1905.
And one of the reasons he wins
the Nobel Prize is he sends Alice,
his charming daughter,
to Asia on a mission.
And she schmoozes with
Asian leaders.
And again, she really helps
him; he negotiates the end
to the Russian-Japanese War.
But again, his child is
helping him in his career.
And so I wrote a piece for
"Politico" about the Trump children
and Chelsea Clinton, is that
we elect not only a president,
we really elect a family.
So maybe we should just check
out, you know, with the children
because they're probably --
especially now when presidents
or candidates are older, their
children are going to, you know,
be around and may be, you know,
involved in some kind of show
of diplomacy just as
Alice was in 1905.
[ Silence ]
All right; here's Grover Cleveland.
Both he and Tyler are another
reason why I believe the claims
that they were double-dealing
dads is both Cleveland
and Tyler marry much younger
women, and they have a kind
of history of being playboys.
And here's Cleveland with
his much younger wife.
She was about 30 years younger.
And here's John Tyler.
And then here's a picture of one
of the slave children of John Tyler
who -- the Tyler picture,
unfortunately, is very small,
but the facial features
are quite similar.
And that's some of
the evidence that --
I don't know if he fathered all 52,
but that there -- so Jefferson --
I mean, you know, Jefferson
and his slave children,
that was all sort of just rumor.
And then people started
to believe it.
And then there should
be evidence there.
And I would -- you know,
I think historians now are
taking the Tyler allegations much
more seriously.
And there isn't DNA proof yet,
but it sounds as though
there's something there,
and I talk about that
in the chapter.
So I think I'll stop here, and I'll
be happy to answer any questions.
[ Applause ]
[ Background Sounds ]
>> I think I read somewhere
that Grant loved his daughter.
>> Joshua Kendall: Yes.
>> He was very disappointing in
the man that she chose to marry.
>> Joshua Kendall: Exactly.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yes.
>> Can you fill in the details?
>> Joshua Kendall:
Yes; it's a very --
>> Josh, could you
repeat the question?
>> Joshua Kendall: So the
question is about Ulysses S. Grant
and his daughter, Nellie
Grant, gets married;
and it's such a touching scene.
She marries this Brit, who --
and Grant is terrified because
she's going to move to England.
And the day of the wedding,
Grant goes into a room
in the White House and
just starts crying.
And it's really sweet.
And this is a guy who's a general
and killed a lot of people,
but he's also got this
very tender side.
And the husband is
horrible and cheats on her,
and her life is just very, very sad.
But her wedding was the social
event of the 19th Century.
And it was a huge -- you know, and
Walt Whitman wrote a poem about it,
and, you know, it was -- and
everyone had such high hopes,
but Grant was heartbroken about
losing his daughter to England,
and it turned out that his
fears were well-grounded.
[ Silence ]
Yes.
>> Mark Russell once told a joke.
He said --
[ Silence ]
"Thomas Jefferson's
slaves used to refer to him
by a term of endearment, 'Daddy'."
Did you find anything to
support or refute that,
because I know there's
a lot of controversy.
>> Joshua Kendall:
Okay; so the question is
about Thomas Jefferson
and his slave children.
Annette Gordon-Reed, the Harvard
historian, has written a couple
of books about that; one of
them won a Pulitzer Prize.
So I've kind of stayed away.
But there is some DNA evidence
that he had six children
with Sally Hemmings, and that
his wife dies around 1782,
and that he has a long-term
relationship with Sally Hemmings,
and that he eventually frees Sally
and the children when he dies.
[ Silence ]
Yes.
>> I don't think you mentioned
Lincoln; is he [inaudible]?
>> Joshua Kendall: Yes; Lincoln
-- it's a great question.
There have been 10,000
Lincoln biographies.
[Laughter] So I decided
to stay away.
But Lincoln I think he comes
up in a couple of categories.
I stick him in grieving dads.
And also in the piece that I
wrote for the New York Times
about Biden I talk a little bit
about this, because Willie dies
in 1862 when he's about 11.
And Pierce immediately writes
Lincoln a letter, and says,
"I know that you're going through."
And Willie was a child -- Lincoln
had four children, it was the one
to whom he was closest, and he talks
about Willie his like other half,
or a very, very intense
relationship.
And Lincoln -- and some of
the Lincoln biographers argue
that this loss kind of hardened him.
And that was just around the
time, the winter of 1862,
when he really steps up the
civil war and it's sort of like,
"Willie's gone, and it's
going to be okay to, you know,
I really have to do
this, and we really have
to step up the war efforts."
So that's a way in which, again,
this loss, you know, again, is --
may be related to national policy;
not always, but that's a theory.
But I just wrote a
piece for "Politico"
about first children
that went to Harvard.
Malia has chosen Harvard.
She is the 23rd first
child, Harvard.
Yale comes in a distant
second at seven.
And the reason I mention
that is Robert Lincoln,
his eldest son, went to Harvard.
And there's a letter that the
Harvard president sends to Lincoln
in 1862, where he says, "Your
kid is failing chemistry.
He needs a talking to."
And Lincoln was a preoccupied
dad with Robert.
So with Willie, he was kind of
a playful dad, because Willie's
at the White House so he can
spend more time with him.
But Robert he didn't see much.
And Robert once says that during
Lincoln's presidency, he never spoke
to him more than ten minutes
because he was so busy.
And Robert, also at Harvard,
gets punished for smoking
in Harvard Square.
He's kind of a -- he's
acting out a little bit,
and was constantly
getting into trouble.
But he does graduate from Harvard
and he goes to Harvard Law School,
but then he doesn't finish.
And Lincoln appoints him
as Grant's assistant.
And again, Robert has like a
Zelig-like role in appomatics.
He's at Grant's side when Grant
meets with Lee in April of 1865.
So that's another way in which these
presidential children kind of pop
up in major moments
in American history.
[ Silence ]
Yes.
>> Did they David Eisenhower
-- if my memory serves,
did he marry [inaudible]?
>> Joshua Kendall: Yes; David
Eisenhower is John's son.
John had -- and I spoke with some
of -- I didn't speak with David,
I spoke with a couple
of his siblings.
Ike was also a Tiger grandfather.
[Laughter] David writes
a memoir about Ike.
And David is about 16 in the
early '60s, and he's working
for Eisenhower at his
farm in Pennsylvania.
And Eisenhower finds out that
he's taking a long lunch break,
and he fires him, [laughter]
the Tiger granddad.
But then he rehires him
the next day, and he says,
"Let's go play some
golf and make up."
But, again, Eisenhower
was a toughie.
>> Was there any other crisscrossing
of presidential families?
>> Joshua Kendall: In
terms of marriages, yes.
I can't think of any
from the top of my head,
but yes he marries
Nixon's daughter, Julie.
And Nixon was kind
of a preoccupied dad.
He would sleep in the Senate
Office Building when he was senator
and even when he was in the White
House, he would often dinner alone.
You know, he was a workaholic.
And again, that's one of the
reasons he became president.
[ Silence ]
Other questions?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
[ Background Sounds ]
>> John Cole: Well, Josh,
thank you very much.
And join me in giving
Josh a round of applause.
[ Applause ]
Josh is, as you can
tell, an avid researcher.
And when he digs, he
digs, and he remembers.
And he's very prolific.
Your books have come out about
once every two years once you
got started.
>> Joshua Kendall: Yes.
>> John Cole: Are you going to tell
us what the next one is going to be?
>> Joshua Kendall: I'm not sure.
I think I'm going to dive into
presidential families again.
I'm not sure exactly the --
>> John Cole: Well, you've certainly
got background for that right now.
>> Joshua Kendall: Yes; I spend
a lot of time [overlapping].
>> John Cole: You should
go on a quiz show as well.
>> Joshua Kendall: Yes.
[Laughter]
>> John Cole: I know which
categories you could pick.
>> Joshua Kendall: Yes.
>> John Cole: But we're
going to have a book signing.
And if you'd like to talk
more with Josh and get --
buy a book at a Library
of Congress discount
and get it signed, now is the time.
The book signing will
be right over here.
We also have, as you go out,
a list of other talks coming
up in our Books and Beyond series,
which is scheduled pretty much
through the rest of the year.
And you'll find that
it's a nice variety
of both books really directly
related to the Library of Congress,
or, in a way, to other
research libraries.
And we're not against promoting
other libraries either.
We like to show the
connections that are needed.
And I know that Josh, for example,
did archival collections in several
of the presidential
libraries, And then, of course,
a lot of the secondary source
material, which is overwhelming,
was used in some of the
rest of the family things.
So you did a great
research job as well.
So a final round of applause for
Josh, and meet him over there.
[ Applause ]
>> Joshua Kendall:
Thank you, [inaudible].
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.